with covid numbers growing this
thanksgiving will be a whole lot
different for so many valley families
eight news now reporter sally jaramillo
spoke to a couple of families and also
some stores about the changes this year
it's hard because we can't celebrate
with families i
invited eight max and then now we're
down to three
it may be an untraditional thanksgiving
not celebrating with family or friends
but many are adapting to changes and
grateful for what they have planned
i ordered the turkey ultimate turkey
package
and it's a whole turkey with sides and
an apple pie
marie calendar's general manager judy
martin says
pre-made meals are in demand that
started on october
october 1st we started taking the orders
as thanksgiving gets closer
immediately you start getting over 60 70
orders per day
to avoid the lines customers started
showing up monday we have a tent set up
outside where you can come and purchase
the pies
we also have a canopy it says feast
that's where you pick up the feast
inside the restaurant you'll be able to
pick up individual dinners
to go or platters family platters food
stores are also seeing an increase of
people planning their turkey dinner
so staff has planned to one of the big
changes that you'll see is now you'll
have someone outside the grocery store
welcoming you into the store
making sure that we're counting the
number of people who are inside
whether it's cooking at home or picking
up a meal safety
is on the minds of everyone and also a
thankful time for those working hard to
help with a new tradition
it's already a stressful time we make it
convenient and easier for them
sally jaramillo 8 news now sally thank
you
it is also recommended if you can to do
curbside pickup or home delivery
services
of the items you need at the store